好,下面我们来给大家介绍一下怎样设置店群。
当您第一次登陆软件的时候,您看到的是这个解密,因为您还没有选择模式。
这时候您需要选择一下店群模式,然后点击"确定"。
然后大家可以看到页面经过刷新之后,上面已经显示出来,当前的模式是店群模式。
然后这边的话,您可以点击我的店群,这里有个提示。
如果您当前的动作账号是"主店",那么您可以点击这个按钮来创建一个店群。
如果是分店的话,您可以先退出去,第一次要用主店来创建店群。
下面我们来点击这个按钮,来创建一个店群。
好了,下面这个店群就已经创建好了。
大家可以看到左边的菜单已经全部都刷新成最新的店群模式的菜单。
然后大家看到这个地方也显示了当前的店群。
可以看到现在店群里面只有当前这个主店的一个号。
那么我们接下来需要把分店都添加进来。
大家可以点击这个添加分店。
在这里把分店的网号输到这里,然后点击确定。
这里有个提示,添加后需要用分店去登录人员进行确认。
我们在这个地方用组电的号已经把分店号添加进来。
但是这里显示的是未确认。
这个时候你还是不能去操作这个分店的。
这需要用分店去确认一下。
我们可以另外一个窗口用分店的号登录一下。
在这个窗口上,大家可以看到用分店的号登录之后也是会提示。
这里选择使用模式,因为分店这个号还没有选择。
同样,您用分店的号也是要选择店群模式。
选完了之后,点这个我的店群。
在这里您可以看到,就是刚才那个组电的号邀请您加入他的店群试播加入。
分店在这里点击确认加入。点击完之后,您可以看到这里提示已经成功的加入店群。
当前的角色是分店。分店已经确认完了。
接下来就不需要用分店再做什么操作了。
咱们可以回到这个组电这边。
在这个组电这里,您可以重新查选一下。
您看到刚才显示的未确认的图标已经没有了。
这里而且它在这个里面的数据也都能显示出来了。
这就说明这个分店已经成功的添加好了。
如果您有多个分店的话,可以点击这个按钮一次的吧。
所有的分店都添加进来。
这样的话,您整个这个店群就设置好了。
设置好店群之后,您后续的操作只需要用组电这个号来登录,登录到软件里面进行操作。
所有的分店都不需要在登录软件去操作了。
包括后面的复制也好,手工的同步,还有实时同步的一些设置啊,查看日啊,都是用组电这个号来登录查看的。
好了,这个店群的配置介绍就到这里。
谢谢。